let me tell you this
what an invite and i am so down and
kristin i'm waiting for you to call me
and tell me about this where we're doing
this and how we're doing this
with your son yeah my son hunter and the
rest of the family is uh just arriving
in l.a and we're getting ready for a big
tailgate event tomorrow and uh but when
this is going down we're only gonna be
here for a short time we gotta make this
party all right a little father-son
moment i'm wearing the this by the way
this is an ongoing problem um wait you
guys show up in the same shirt and you
don't know it no we always match
everything we wear we always match
somehow where do you think he gets the
clothes from the thing so he lives in it
he has his own house but we'll go to do
an event and we almost get to that point
now where we have to say all right hey
don't wear the chicken guys shirt all
right don't wear the knuckles yeah
exactly look the clothes the good looks
the talent we like you got it out from
his mother he's not from me
so if anybody can do a tailgate
obviously it's you two what can we
expect from the tailgate the tailgate is
the party i mean the super bowl is the
greatest sporting event well beside the
nba all-stars but anyhow
the tailgate is so amazing and what it
is it's
the best chefs in the country all come
together so we're able to like we're
here in l.a so we have antonio faso
we've got
michael voltaggio aaron may i mean all
these great chefs are coming in so it's
great food
great cocktails bud light seltzer you
know we just did this big commercial
with them which is amazing but light
heart the hard soda um and then it's
awesome music djire and then we have
over 50 players that show up so it's a
place i mean when you're gearing up for
the big game
this is the place to go so if you have
have you been to it by the way
i think you need to bring the camera i
think you i bring the camera or not you
need to come down thank you it is a
blast i'm beyond sold tonight last
question we're here at the fanatics
party who are you excited to see we got
some amazing performances why is this
the party you have to come to well uh
michael's good buddy and honestly we
have to we are in to say hello get a
high five have a have have a drink and
we have the mounts because we have all
these engagements but you cannot have
the fanatics party and not show up
that's if you want to be invited back
next year but he throws i mean they
throw the best party they are the
biggest the biggest name in the game and
uh you know everybody's excited to be
here and so we had to at least come in
say hi have a good time for 45 minutes
and boogie amazing i love it you got
places to be yes oh hold on is one place
you have to be officiating kristen
stewart's wedding
let me tell you this
what an invite and i am so down and
kristen i'm waiting for you to call me
and tell me about this where we're doing
this and how we're doing this but i
think that's the coolest you know so
i've officiated a few weddings i did i
actually officiated 100
101 um
uh couples in miami i think it was one
of the largest uh
i don't know one of the largest gay
weddings that was ever done and it was
an honor you know it was really an honor
to do that and to see these people
celebrating their lives together and
then finally having that union and that
bond and i was the guy that got to
present that to him or you know
participate in it with him so when she
called me and said or would she
announce that and said would guy do it
i'm like
sister let's do this so you're just
waiting for the call tell me where you
actually tell me where and when oh did
you see your reaction
i mean you can do the food too
what is it a package deal oh look you
got a lot of stuff if i could sing folks
look emc it you guys got it all
you